[Arabic recitation]
bath house
and
or did we not mention it yet?
[Arabic recitation]
just the bath house.
thing we mentioned. Oh, well then I
didn't tell you yet. Subhan Allah. I'm
asking you to tell me something. I
didn't tell you
the fourth place.
And this is something that is going to
be extremely rare for any of us to ever
have to practice. You never know, right?
It's good to have this knowledge, but I
doubt that any of us will find ourselves
in this predicament anytime soon. for
[Silence]
on the authority of
Allah.
He narrates that the messenger of Allah
Sam
was asked about a person performing
salah in the living in the pen or the
living area of camels.
so you know how horses have a
corral that they live in and
chickens have a coupe and goats have a
pen, right? Well, camels would have like
a
I don't know what it's called in
English, but it's a it's kind of a
pen where they live in, right? this
is referred to as
meaning in the places where the camels
lay down, where they sleep, where they,
you know, are kept when they're not out.
And so
he was asked about the permissibility of
performing prayer
in the camel's enclosure.
And he said, "Do not pray in a camel's
enclosure,
for indeed it is of a shaim."
Right? And then he was asked about the
validity of performing prayer in the
pen of sheep and goats. And he said
it is permissible to pray in them. pray
in them in their pens for indeed sheep
and goats are baraka. Now
this here is the fourth place that would
make prayer invalid if a person were to
make it there. If a person were to pray
in the enclosure of camels and what's
meant by the enclosure of camels is the
place where they live,
right? And this is unexpected
because camels are permissible. They are
halal
and their urine and their droppings is
not considered a type of nessa,
right? It's considered to be
they're considered to be pure creatures.
However,
where they reside and their
enclosures, it's not permissible to prey
in their enclosures.
However, what about the enclosures of
other animals that are permissible?
Cows, sheep, goats, permissible.
And the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam.
He mentions regarding the first.
What does that mean?
That the camels are from
doesn't mean that they are devils or
they are evil. It just means that
camels have particular
behavior, sets of behavior that
set them aside from the rest of
domesticated animals and spending too
much time with them will impact and
impress upon a person. And as for the
goats and sheep, the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam responded.
He said, "Pray in those places for
indeed they are baraka." Meaning that
goats and sheep they are of
they are blessed. And actually one of
the only animals
that we heard
on earth, the sheep
is actually one of the type
of animals of paradise. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam mentioned
that the sheep
is one of the types of animals of
paradise. And so this makes four
four places where if a person prays
in these places the prayer is what?
Invalid. Now
it doesn't mean that all other places
are equal. There may be some places
which are
less conducive,
less preferable for a person to make
salah in them. But what's important is
that as far as valid
and invalid is concerned,
it is four places. Number one, the grave
site. Number two, the cemetery.
Number three, the bath house. And number
four, the pens and enclosures of camels.
I learn a Muhammad.
[Arabic recitation]